today I think what we're going to do
we're going to look at a few positions
and basically talk about you know how to
evaluate them what factors are important
in evaluating positions and how to
create plans I think you know that's you
know these basic things every test bar
needs to know how to do well so let's
start from this end game position
White's last move was pawned 'if from
efore to e5 so I'm going to give you um
a minute or two to think about what
you'd like to do for black and also to
make an evaluation of the position and
explain why you think it favors one side
or the other or you know maybe it's
equal okay you want to play d5 that's an
interesting choice you're trying to get
some strong pawns there for black what
happens if i take with what okay with
your night so i got a take with my
bishop okay and you want to go for this
work endgame interesting okay
yes now i have a choice right I can play
rook c1 or I can trade rooks and maybe
play rook c5 mm-hmm interesting well
let's try this one first rook takes rook
takes and I don't want to let if your
pawn was here right now I would be
completely lost because I wouldn't be
able to stop his promotion so I
definitely have to stop the pawn from
going to c3 right now right that's
pretty clear okay so I'll go here right
well there's no question that black is
doing you know fairly well here
I mean the rock is very active although
you know it's in front of the pass pawn
so
hmm okay let's let's start by I'm
curious to see how you're going to make
progress here let's say I played King to
f1 so you want to play g5 yes this is an
interesting idea trying to undermine
White's pawns definitely interesting
let's say I played three let's move that
pawn out of attack since wasn't very
good age to anyway
do you think it's going to be easy to
win the son game it's not all because
here's the problem first of all your
king can actually not help out the rook
right like your Kings in a little box
right now you can bring it here and then
it's not going anywhere you can bring it
here and it's not going anywhere right
so it has no way to make any progress in
this direction your idea g5 you know I
support it's a good idea but your King
like even if you capture here and you
try to bring your king in here this
takes too long and when your King starts
moving this way my e pawn can also start
to advance right so not so easy and
basically what's going to happen is like
say you push this pawn here but after
that your rook can't move this way
because you lose the pawn if you move
your work this way well let's say I just
kind of stay where I am okay let's say
here your moves this way you know this
position I don't see how you can make
any progress in right this is a typical
kind of position where the rook is
unfortunately placed in front of its
past pawn and it has no tricky moves
here on the first rank
so you're the work is tied down and the
King cannot be making progress by the
way guys to notice I put my King on this
square um why didn't I put it here who
knows everyone should know this idea in
a rook endgame
I mean I'm not saying this move is
losing in this particular moment but the
general idea is you don't want to fall
for a tactic in this position where
black can play rook age-1 force you to
take on c2 and then win your work
actually when I was a kid I won one game
like that so the King in these types of
positions right the only thing you don't
want to fall for is this type of move
where the rook is able to unblock the
pawn and due to this tactical trick
white can't you know take it so you want
your king to be here or here these are
the two key squares I mean in this
particular position it's a sea pawn you
actually could have your king here
because when they give you a check on a
second rank you're in time to be
protecting your rook but I just wanted
to you know points out this useful
tactical trick because it does come up
and work end games so basically what can
we say um we went for this position
right which arose basically by force
right this work ends game from your line
but our advantage here is not so great
you know they say all work end games are
drawn and here um you know it looks to
be the case nothing is so fatally
terrible about whites position that he
has to lose just because this pawn is
strong White's rook is rather active a
pawn is good the king is passive but you
know you know the positions start with
was equal interesting ah you know d5 is
an interesting move and there are some
ways that black could also make some
alternative moves for example this
little tactical shot is possible in this
position using the pin on the b-pawn you
can try to advance your pawn a little
bit further you know play for example um
some kind of endgame like this you have
two rooks on the board if white black
takes this way actually this is not so
good because this pawn is going to be
lost on c3 I'm sure you know something
like that
unfortunately black has no way to
protect it black could capture this way
and again you know we're in some kind of
a rook endgame can we win it you know
our ruckus are obviously black is better
here you know this is very strong pawn
but the rooks also are kind of tied down
to protecting it so you know white can
count on I think you know some sort of
defense the King will come up and even
though white is passive I'm not sure how
easily black can make progress although
in this position I think actually black
chances are better here than in the
single Brook endgame that we saw black
probably should make this move g5 and he
has flexibility to try to get his King
in white is very very um tied down here
I mean it is possible to play d5 I think
that blacks position remains better so
you think this position is equal well
let's say we make a very simple move
right we should definitely look at this
capture simple move to look at let's try
to evaluate this position so here we
haven't liquidated material right so we
haven't gone on this forcing line where
both minor pieces get traded on the game
stays a little bit more complicated
let's try to evaluate this position why
do you think it's equal
but isn't there a difference in chests
between being active and being passive
if someone is actively attacking
something and you're just passively
defending it even though you're not
losing it for now it doesn't really
equalize to the same thing right and I
don't think so because uh in every
passive position or the seeds of defeat
my coach likes to say that never heard
that guys yes no okay well remember that
it's very useful because I do think you
know um when people are starting out
they tend to under appreciate this idea
you know they think they can hold
positions passively you know if you're
not losing the B to pawn right away so
they might think this is okay for white
and it's true black is not able to win
this pawn right away but there are other
things going on in this position so
let's try to figure out why this is not
an equal position actually blacks Knight
is probably the um his relatively worst
piece right now that he needs to now
focus on improving c6
maybe mm-hmm maybe I mean it's
definitely a possible square um it makes
a lot of sense I agree with you yes
that's true I mean I think if you made
this move the the inclusion of the night
into the game is so dangerous for white
that white immediately has to make a
trade a bishop for Knight and you know
get rid of that Knight
yes
actually I like your idea I think in
this position this move certainly it's
one of those things that is like a
little tactical move that positionally
improves your position because okay this
is our immediate threats winning the
Knights the knight doesn't have any good
squares I mean as soon as it moves white
always has to look at it you know this
tactical idea of c3 on the same pin
being used on the b-pawn so very likely
they're going to be making some move
like that right they're going to try to
hold their Knight there um but this move
right you know there are some tactical
ideas like this but it's not even like
the most dangerous um you know thing for
for whites because you know we can take
and on this move maybe we play here you
know maybe this is very bad I mean well
there's ninety six right this is why
white holds on and even stays up a pawn
um but okay FFF four is an interesting
tactical idea we should always have our
eyes open for such things but even if we
just play very simply here I mean I like
the move rugby three because it doesn't
cost black anything and it makes White's
pieces more passive you see the rook is
better of course on the D file even
though it's not doing anything concrete
than it is on the C file so for free we
made our opponents piece more passive
now it's time to add some extra pieces
into our um I would say into our attack
I would always say into our attack
except you know we don't actually have
an attack on the King now but still we
have some sort of initiative against
White's position right we need to add in
some more power because what we have
right now is not enough so who do we
need to add which piece are we going to
improve
right how do you want to improve the
bishop I mean other than this idea of
sacking the pawn and opening it up this
way how no idea well it's important not
only to see you know what we want to
improve but also to have some kind of
vision for how we're going to do it this
Bishop even though it looks like it's
not so great right staring into this
pond it's actually doing a pretty useful
job for black because making sure this
pawn is protected means that black other
than this pawn has no other weaknesses
in his position right Bishop also guards
this square it also used to be guarding
this square so there you know earlier
there was no working filtration there
either
the bishop is actually not so bad it's
not a pretty good squared I don't see
how we're going to make it better by
like moving it back somewhere so bishop
is fine but the knight right it's now
it's currently contributing in any way
to blacks otherwise strong position how
do we make it better well you can but
you know why I mean you know sacking a
pawn in the endgame it's kind of a big
decision so in this particular position
um you know is it warranted that's the
question are you getting so much value
from your knight being an f5 that it was
worth stacking like an entire pawn for
right well there are lots of moves um
where do you want to go into e3 I mean
even in itself this is not such a big
threats because in the worst case my
rook moves and you know you trade your
knight for my bishop I mean let's say I
make this move I mean I really have a
lot of moves here there's 94 that's
interesting even if I make this move ah
you want to go Knight e3 right and I can
go here because right now my bishop is
protecting my rook so there's no rook c3
idea
well it's interesting pong sack to
improve the night but it seems like very
radical right for this relatively simple
position you know I think black can
improve um simple means and there's no
reason to start sacking material y si
pong it's not protective its weak its
isolated and it's a target now what I
would do is go g5 and then what right so
this is the this is the basic plan that
black should be carrying out now accepts
you know I like to start it with the
move rugby 3 because like we saw it
doesn't doesn't hurt black in any way
forces the rook there and then I think
this move you know just focusing on
making the pieces that we have better so
g5 the night will come here and start
attacking the other weakness and White's
position you know when you start zoning
in on your opponent's weaknesses you
know his position is going to fall apart
because you can see over here he lacks
resources to defend right his rooks are
tied down to one weakness his bishop
cannot help defend a dark-squared pawn
and his knight cannot move and so it's a
very simple moves like that you know
just adding the right amount of
reinforcements you can basically break
down White's position so from the
starting point I would wanted to say
that um you know this is an interesting
decision but when you play this move you
should realize like okay hey we're going
to be in like a rook endgame here or
like a double rook ends game you know
those tend to be draws
right so I might be letting a large part
of my advantage escape you also let your
opponent's keep a strong pawn on e5 so
you're not like ruining their pawn
structure so it's a little bit like
unless you see very concrete dividends
like you're sure that the past pawn that
you're going to have the C pawn is going
to just like you know win the game for
you I would be kind of hesitant about
that move but this move right simple one
to make and here you are by force in
this position and here it's very
dear you have kept your opponent's
weakness on b2 that's weakness number
one this is a weakness number two do you
have any similar weaknesses no right
that's why position like this is not
equal even though you're not like
winning material right away when your
opponents has weaknesses when your rooks
when the most valuable pieces on the
board right which is like the pair of
rooks are better than your opponent's
rooks you know those things add up to
pretty large advantage yes right sure
well that's why this pawn is a weakness
right we I mean obviously if the pawn
was right here
it wouldn't we wouldn't count it as a
weakness white would only have one
weakness but yes this pawn is isolated
and that's what makes it weak so and
we're in chess we're always looking for
ways to maximally use our pieces so
that's why I would focus right now on
this night on e7 and just adding it
putting it on a good square basically
you know should all be the winning plan
for black okay okay guys so this is our
next example it's it's white to move and
try to figure out a plan for white to
proceed you know what would your next
move be for white or your maybe the plan
that you're trying to carry out
short-term plan
okay rook a d1 so this is a pretty
natural move for white to make obviously
cannot be too bad bringing a rook that's
not doing anything to the center of the
board on the semi open file okay let's
say black plays something like b4 so by
the way this kind of should have been
considered because um black has a couple
of pieces pointing at this important
square so we have to know what we're
doing on the move b4 sorry
taking on f6 right well it looks like if
you drop in on this square this might
have some tactical problems because the
knight is going to capture well if you
capture here first then of course we
take back with the night we stay up a
piece so and if you take with the bishop
then we're going to take your bishop and
unfortunately this position is not equal
or better for white because black has a
move that wins the bishop stays up a
piece so there's some tactical you know
things going on in the center here right
95 it's definitely you know positionally
it's a fine move but you've got to
calculate like what's going on when
exchanges start happening in the center
you know there's this diagonal the
pieces are lined up here so you were
seeing Bishop f6 right okay that is true
you should take there and let's say I
take ninety five okay
maybe a five protects the b4 pawn gives
us some ideas of a four maybe sometimes
Bishop a six so do you guys understand
um you probably it's not really clear
why I'm showing this example or what I'm
trying to get at so far okay so maybe
let me try to help you in this have you
guys are you familiar with this type of
structure what opening is it from its
from a Sicilian right and what is the
positional battle revolving around here
this square very good so a white would
like to occupy the square in the most
effective way possible right so what was
our first move reference was rook D 1 B
4 so we saw that immediately this
occupation doesn't work so very often
white uses this technique of treating
his Bishop on g5 for this night and f6
normally you know you don't want to just
trade bishops for Knights but here
there's a very good reason to do that
because you want to occupy the square
Knight to d5 now so we're sort of
understanding everything is about this
d5 square um what do you guys think
blacks should do okay I mean obviously I
suggested this move but black has some
alternatives for example maybe Bishop
takes d5 maybe he should trade that
Bishop for the strong Knights and play
the position with bishops of opposite
color you know which are often known to
be pretty equal what do you think about
that strategy
right what do you guys know about
opposite colored bishops in the middle
game they favor the attacker right so
it's true you know like in this type of
position if we took the Queens off the
board
took both pairs of rooks off the board
that that would be very draw right
because of the bishops of opposite color
but because we're still in the middle
game um and it's definitely true that
white's bishop is more effective than
blacks in this position so white still
has the advantage despite the bishops of
opposite color and they're sort of
drawing tendencies in the middle game
actually bishop adopts the color make it
easier to attack for example this pawn
always going to be an Achilles and
Achilles heel for black Bishop is rather
passive and even if you put it here this
is a rather empty diagonal so the bishop
has a hard time really finding something
to do I suppose you know what you would
ideally like to do is transfer him maybe
here but if you did that even if you
accomplish that then Y would have
attacking ideas with the move f6 right
so White has a space advantage this pawn
is quite powerful and that's what makes
it difficult for this Bishop to ever be
removed from the square there is this
you know target on f7 so you know White
has a pretty pretty Lake you know
significant advantage here is not like a
winning position but it's pleasant so
that's why it's not a panacea right to
just trade your Bishop for the strong
Knight that's why first we try this move
keeping the bishop someone in blacks
camp needs to try to control the d5
square yes
well we're going to take a look at that
but you see in this position guys um
white has not really stabilized his
advantage
despite having good control over the d5
square black still has one piece that is
fighting for control over that square
and if you trade your lesser your night
for the bishop right which obviously
maybe you're not so happy to do because
that Bishop wasn't very strong you know
you can't just win the d6 pawn so easily
right because for example efore is
hanging right so even if I did something
like that or maybe even taking it right
away
um not clear you know I don't think
actually black is worse than this
endgame black who knows you know black
is threatening a for the c2 pawn is a
week so you can um go that's route
meanwhile you know um hmm oh yeah there
are these bishop a6 ideas although you
still have Bishop c4 there may be a four
is my main um my main source of
counterplay a4 Bishop c4 I mean actually
kind of still looks I prefer white by
the way because it's not easy for black
to solve the problem of this poor Bishop
and he can't move his queen away from it
either so I still prefer white um but
the you know it's not so bad for black
yet in this initial position though you
were asking me about this move right
okay Bishop f6 more direct way to try to
gain that square here and now what did
you want to do this shove d5 very good
you see because you didn't waste time on
the move rook d1 and allow a black time
to you know play before attack your
knight you have time to actually force a
trade of the only piece of blacks that
can control the d5 square and this
stabilizes White's advantage without any
doubt because that's it then it's going
to be this night versus that Bishop then
it's very easy right to play it's like
the ideal thing that you want to have
this position very nice positional
decision now I just thought when we were
looking at this variation of you know
rook d1 and B for Bishop takes f6 here
and here I thought of a way to explain
why white is not getting the maximum
here that he would like but there's sort
of a principle here at work which is
going to be very useful for you guys to
remember I mean like I just kind of
formulated it as remembered to formulate
it as I saw this now I didn't realize it
was actually even taking place so any
idea I know what I just said probably
didn't help steer you towards it towards
what I'm thinking about yeah the
question is what principle is at work
here that's actually preventing white
from having a big advantage there's
white is a little problem in White's
position what he's doing what he's done
mm-hmm no okay
so here remember this idea guys
extremely important in chess and we
forget about all the time
now um the the knight on d5 is pretty
good right now what about this bishop
wouldn't it be pretty good on d5 - yeah
you see how these pieces are competing
for one square right that's the problem
it looks like it's hard to think that
way because we think oh the bishop
supporting the knight they're both good
actually no there's a little bit too
many people who would like to be on that
square
you see it's better to get rid of one of
them because actually the knight here
yet he's good but he makes the bishop
less effective than he could be so might
better just have these guys off the
board then you know the knight is the
natural sort of a occupier of that
square so that's an idea that um I mean
it's actually kind of an advanced rity
jerk idea and I can show you an example
on that I forget about it all the time
you know and let me show you an example
you'll see what I mean
so basically the lesson from this
example is about how to effectively
occupy a weak square right and that you
don't want to pieces competing for the
same square so that's all you need to
remember from this example any questions
yes this is kind of an example the rest
of the game I can show you the rest of
the game we can create it I can yes the
beautiful game well which side do you
want to play on I guess you like white I
mean we can we can create a game here um
so let's say you take here and I take
and you go here right all right I will
try will suffer here a little bit there
is a game with Smith lob is very similar
to this exactly miss La Rue de coughs
Kenneth I have this example in my file
it wasn't that but it's extremely
similar yes extremely similar so I
didn't think there was any reason to
show to twice but the basic idea is um I
mean yeah after this exchange of bishops
black is just paralyzed because the
knight on d5 I mean I miss love in a
very similar position er he put his pawn
on c3 brought the rook to d1 you know
black cannot move because as soon as
this bishop moves f6 comes and white
starts an attack on the king it's always
in the library of in the club yeah I
mean I'm sure I'm sure absurd there it's
not very instructive game yeah
right exactly it can't ever be kicked
and by the way of course guys the even
though without these pieces on the board
White has an advantage for sure White
has a bigger advantage which is just
night versus Bishop rather than Bishop
versus Bishop here the advantage is like
the most you can ever get this is the
most white can ever hope for it's like
the dream position from something like
over here because they have established
total domination over the square which
was what you know their positional aim
right so to that you know for that aim
they were willing to trade off their
Bishop for the knight which you know by
the way you don't always want to do
right and they also occupied the square
with a correct piece forcing that trade
black can't even avoid it you know
because of the rook and the bishop on
the same diagonal they can give a check
but that doesn't actually change
anything and you know that's it
strategically the game is won once it
gets to this point um because yeah
fortunately you have a big problem with
this Bishop is just horrible and if you
just change the color bishops at least
it was that kind of Bishop then it'd be
a different story right so we got that
okay so let me show you an example on
the problem of two pieces competing for
the same square in this position it is
black to move so Cara Juana was playing
black and I'm going to show you what he
did well
first kind of a custom yourselves to
this position what is blacks main
problem here guys okay that is true this
is a kind of an isolated weak pawn right
the bishop is terrible of course our
main problem in chess guys is pieces
right if a piece is bad it's
incomparably worse than just having you
know a weak pawn this Bishop if we could
put it on a decent square um our
position wouldn't be so bad so here is a
very interesting maneuver that Cara
Juana came up with
he played Bishop e6 rook moves away it
was attacked and then what seems like
you know extremely clever I was very
impressed Knight b6 what is black trying
to do with that move I mean why would
the knight move away from a wonderful
position on d5 to b6 yes right exactly
now obviously actually this is a move
very hard for white to stop because
white is definitely not interested in
making that trade and improving black's
pawn structure right that's for sure
this would be you know probably just
already better for black you know next
block and move this Queen to this nice
square the bishop pair is no problem
with the pawn structure so white doesn't
do that the white played Knight c5 very
logical black played here and the Queen
moves away and black out his Bishop here
I mean it wasn't this like really clever
by black I mean look at that that Bishop
used to be horrible and now he's in the
center of the board like he can't be
attacked just a beautiful piece right
and then we go further you know okay so
we've got this position I'll just show
you the course of the game a little bit
white occupy this square with his knight
by the way very hard for black to get
counter play right look at the way white
is controlling the center black tried to
activate his Queen a white played here I
think the idea is to make sure this
night never goes anywhere nice to
contain our opponent's pieces Black's
not doesn't have a whole lot of counter
play now we blunt the bishop block tries
to get rid of this Knight moves away h5
he's trying to do something active
f5 attack on this pawn so the bishop
comes out this way
rook D 823 basically um you see black
has been you know in his quest for
counter play has weakened his position
quite a bit you know h5 f5 um you know
then the game got kind of tactical white
was better and white really way should
have won this game he actually was kind
of a heartbreaking thing that he didn't
win he actually let Cora wanna escape
with a draw even though he was up in
exchange um but seeing this game I
thought how come black never equalized I
mean doesn't he have this really strong
Bishop on d5
yeah then it came to my coach we know
when I shall show this to Mexico kuranes
maneuver is not good you know because
actually two pieces are competing for
the same square right I mean that was
hard for me to imagine because I thought
well okay well this surely the night is
not as bad here as that Bishop used to
be on c8 but it turns out that the whole
uh you know blacks problems here are not
solved because of that idea two pieces
are competing for the same square and I
asked him you know how should have black
you know treated this position instead
of Bishop a six you came up with a very
interesting move well not just a move
but a concept so first you know you put
your Queen so pretty good square well
why it's going to play something like
rook you won and rook e8 so we actually
saw Cara wanna partly carrying out
things like that not a total surprise
and f6 you know not letting this Knight
jump to that square so all this is maybe
not so obvious you know closing in this
Bishop but the reality is the bishop
could not do anything on this diagonal
anyway um and the general idea is here
let's say rook c1 Bishop d7 so it looks
paradoxical like we're not actually
making this piece better but
we have a very nice plan for making it
better like that and actually the idea
is at some point just to play g5 expand
and that Bishop can be let out on this
diagonal block has you know some latent
power in his position here because of
the bishop here but it's good I mean
obviously it's taking a lot of moves for
him to carry out this plan and the
concept is like very deep so um I can
tell you for sure I wouldn't be able to
find this type of thing in a game I
would be you know more straightforward
you know and be like exactly like what
Cara wanna did just seemed brilliant to
me you know so that's why it's a tricky
concept you know to keep in mind of how
not to you know run into the problem of
having two pieces competing for the same
square but because they're not competing
for the same square here black has a way
to get a lot more out of them right when
you play g5 and you play like Bishop h5
or Bishop g6 right and you bring your
other rook to e8 if you need to
protection of that pawn um you know you
can even think g5 g4 get counter play
started over there so anyway that's
advanced you know but I just wanted to
give you an illustration on this theme
okay guys take a look at this position
and tell me you know which side you
prefer I'll give you a minute to think
about it yes
why
okay very good
um well the number one thing that is by
going against white in this position for
my point of view is this bishop right so
I see white having a pretty poor bishop
behind the pawn chain and no real
potential for getting him out so I'm
just very worried about White's position
just based on at one point because one
bad piece makes their entire position
that very often that's just just the
just a reality so the rest of our pieces
can be okay but one bad piece is going
to bring our position down so the other
thing is black has a very strong outpost
for the 94 right supported by these two
pawns and of course blacks Bishop is
fine compared to whites I mean black has
a dark squared Bishop the pawns are not
you know blocking heaven so I also would
prefer block all right imagine now um
white exchanged Knights which way should
lock be recapturing
right f takes undable your pawns why not
like why bother giving white you know
some strong mobile pawns in the center
this is a natural recapture okay and the
knight doesn't have a whole lot of
squares it's going to go back here okay
so take a minute and tell me what move
you would play here for black and like
what your plan is
yes f5 - and asia's - Pelotonia file we
double up on it come down because
they're white star square bishops over
here and kinda bow to play why do you
think it's audacious I mean you think
your poems going to tell you that you're
- insolence how dare you or what
it's just an always dangerous to be or
saying okay what about the guy sitting
next to you what do you think so does
anyone in this room not like the move f5
or feel like some other move might be an
equally good alternative or has anything
else to add yes uh-huh
so what you don't want wait to play b4
but you're not actually able to prevent
me from playing before you like let's
say I play b3 what does that change like
I can still get in this plan if I really
want you stalled it
that's interesting I mean a five let's
think about that so blacks idea I guess
is that if I play rugby one you want to
play a four right kind of a King's
Indian type of idea of stalling White's
counter play on the Queen side a four
and I cannot easily win that pawn
because my knight is not on c3 mmm okay
iced tea what if I play here though what
if I say okay I can live with that pawn
because hey I need to counter play
somewhere obviously you're going to take
right because there's nothing to be
gained by not taking let's say you take
and I take with my rook works not too
badly placed on v3
now I'm going to force you to play
something like 4k 7 right not a not bad
square for the rook the rook is still
pressuring on the a file and also
defending that poem but someone needs to
protect this guy right what do you think
yeah I mean you can go Queen c8 but it
doesn't really change anything that pawn
is going to require some more protection
soon or maybe 95 you wanted to play well
definitely not this one right because
why not keep a rook as active as
possible on you know working on a file
at the same time as defending b7 you
want to looks a lot more attractive from
a7 okay well I got to tell you White's
minor pieces are awful here so I don't
you know i don't love positions where my
knight and bishop look like this but at
least my i have one piece now that is
looking like not too bad all mium can't
say much more than that we can't wait a
chance to do some stuff yeah before none
of his pieces really had any right right
make any other move on a board that I
wanted and mmhmm yeah not a white Jesus
well I agree with you and I think you
know 85 is an interesting you know
prophylactic idea um but it does you
know in this position give us some sort
of you're opening up some lines there on
the Queen side at least giving me a
chance to put make one active piece and
tell you down a little bit right in
general you know you know what pawn
chains are their clue givers right about
where you should be playing likewise
pawn chain points this way so white
should be playing on the Queen side
while black's pawn chain is pointing
towards the king side that's where
obviously black should be playing so I
don't think you know this idea just in
itself is not like super dangerous um
for black and
back to think of the night is awful here
isn't it I would be happy if you make me
move to some better square because I
don't really like my knight on c6
everything about blacks position is
great except the night on which could be
improved so it's not the end of the
world but because it doesn't have any
central squares or any prospects of
anything I think the night is one of the
candidates for improvements in this
position did you guys notice that yes
this night is not so good even though it
looks like it looks ok so I absolutely
agree though I would start with this
move to me it just seems like the most
natural move in the position and there
are so many things that this move allows
black to do I mean there is the f-4 idea
right followed by f3 opening up the king
like that maybe you'll take on e3 and
play Bishop g5 maybe you want to make
this move maybe you want to transfer
your queen over this way right bringing
your queen into the table into the onto
the King side maybe at some point you
want to move your rook on the 6th rank
like that you know so basically this
move you know I'm not sure which exact
plan black is going to start with maybe
maybe they just want to do like Queen d7
rook f6 work a to f8 right and then f4
get both rooks doubled up and then play
a four so but it's I'm not sure which of
those plans you know we're going to do
it depends also on what white plays but
for sure you know f5 has to be the right
idea right the pawn structure tells us
that our space advantage you know due to
the e4 pawn gives us a space advantage
on the King side and f5 is the move that
opens up the rook and seeks to take
advantage of that you know the space
advantage so it's a move that's hard to
criticize f5 okay